amine rêve du titre national salim de la
ceinture mondiale sur le ring ces deux
frères ont pourtant des stratégies bien
différentes pour l'emporter
j'analyse comment l'adversaire bock le
premier rôle c'est surtout une analyse
et ensuite j'ai coupé conseils de
l'entraîneur et j'essaye de m'y adapter
c'est de reculer en tapant les laisse
s'avancer sur moi et quand tu mets
découvert sa garde à vue cet appel à la
garde des sceaux
la saison passée à mine s'était incliné
en finale inter régionale contre le
futur champion de france
autant dire que le championnat
départemental n'était qu'une formalité
mais quand même il est niveau national
donc là on est sur du départemental qui
aboutira justement sur du national
donc oui à ce niveau là j'ai pas de
surprise mais bon en même temps c'est
pas sur qui on tombe en phase donc on
peut avoir des surprises d'elle
départementale c'est justement parce que
c'est un championnat comme attendu salim
et amine s'impose pour la troisième fois
dans leur catégorie respective
ces jeunes boxeurs glanent leur premier
titre sous le regard d'un modèle ahmed
el moussaoui nouveau champion de france
de boxe des welters a mis les grands
pour la première fois sur ce ring mais
tous passés par la boxe éducative
en plus de ça moi j'ai commencéà à la
verrière et j'avais 8 ans et mon premier
assaut éducatif je les fais ici et voilà
c'est des bons souvenirs et je suis
content parce qu'aujourd'hui j'ai vu des
petits qui sont vraiment pas mal voilà
j'espère que qui vont souvent sur mon
chemin
pour la seconde année consécutive le
boxing de la verrière est le premier
club des yvelines avec 11 titres
départementaux